[Music]
a steady increase of copic 19
vaccinations in our state and
we're now reporting 1.2 million people
have received the shot so far
that's right denise well here in clark
county more than 919
thousand people have been given the
covet 19 dose and about a third of a
million people
are fully vaccinated but as kristin
drummond shows us some question
the vaccination card and why the
verification is a piece of paper instead
of digital
the state tells me the cdc issued the
forms to track and verify the covit 19
doses
that piece of paper is a medical record
and can also be an inconvenience for
some
since it's not digital to prove their
vaccination be able to have
either a qr code i think would be kind
of cool mary randina proudly shows her
covet 19
vaccination card i went and got the
johnson johnson because i just wanted to
be
one and done she likes convenience and
wants it with
this paper everything else is digital
except for that not everyone
has access to digital technology and so
this is a way that
will help us meet our you know governor
syslax focus on equitability
and access across the board the state
plans to keep the forms
but are considering potential digital
options working on
making sure that we have the
infrastructure in place to do that
and working with our private sector
partners new york launched the first
covit 19 vaccine digital passport
people there can use an app on their
phone to prove their vaccination or
show they've recently tested negative
for the virus we need a system that
works together from state to state so
you don't have to have 50 different
vaccine passports brian labus an
infectious disease epidemiologist at
unlv tells me
the card was not designed to show proof
of immunization
but as randina and others begin to
travel and go out
i'm going to take a photo of it also and
just so i have a backup of it
they plan to keep it nearby kristin
drummond 8 news now
and boulder says